there's so many men's issues that we
need to bring up I agree and have
highest suicide rates they're working
harder jobs yes the pay Gap
arguably does not exist do we agree on
this yeah I agree perfect yes but that
does not mean that feminism is a Female
Supremacy movement I think it is
feminism what's the definition what
definition do you give it the definition
well they talk about equality but they
don't mean it so you don't mean it
because in definition
and Define it for the rest of women
everywhere when there's women out there
that are being abused when this woman
out there that have a higher chance of
domestic violence and you're going to
stand for majority in Leicester Square
where there's women passing by that are
probably in domestic
problems
okay cut me off cut me off because I'm
making a good point cut me off I hope
you guys really come on keep going go
ahead I will keep going because I'm
making a good point that's why you don't
want to interrupt me yeah I hope you
guys honestly feel like you guys are
spreading a good message because all the
women out here aren't feeling that you
are okay